when I think of dr. Martin Luther King
and his legacy I think of innovation I
think of equality I think of the
importance of having personal dialogue i
think is servitude
he's a hero and a visionary in the sense
that he's given so much to this country
in this nation and the one lesson that
stood most was me is best summarized by
pulte he was gay and it's called the
ultimate measure of a man also a measure
of a man is not where he stands in
moments of comfort and convenience where
he stands at times challenging
controversy and that to me says a lot
about her strength and character I feel
that as a carnegie-mellon student um
times get really tough so from the cold
I just gave it teaches it to just
continue to stay strong I think one of
the lessons that I take away from the
work that Martin Luther King jr. did is
innovation I think that it's just not
selling for the status quo is ensuring
that you continue to push the barriers
and you continue to demand more and you
continue to fight I thank dr. Martin
Luther King jr. really tell people about
how to be yourself and be your own
person no matter who you are I'm part of
best buddies here at Carnegie Mellon and
our program pairs us up with adults who
have disabilities in the community so I
think what I've learned and taken away
from best buddies is the idea that
people who might be labeled as different
and maybe like unable to do things are
really awesome people but I think about
Martin Luther King jr. equality probably
is the top lesson or value that comes to
moment I think of him being in the arts
I think you have to accept the idea of
equality and that everybody is in the
same playing field no matter what the
background or the race or religion that
you all share a common denominator and
that being the arts so uh the one thing
that comes to my mind is the importance
of bringing issues to the forefront and
and really encouraging people to talk
about it I think his legacy is is that
he motivated people and he brought that
issue to people and they were like oh
this is something that we need to deal
with this thing that we need to talk
about it I think he embodied what it
meant to the whole quote in that two say
people you must serve people to lead
people you must love people